il est chic il soigne son look il est
super branché en communication pour lui
le feedback n'a pas de secret il vient
de se lancer dans un grand trip
médiatique ce jeune homme élégant nippe
mais qui sait faire de la monnaie
son nom
[Musique]
je vais imaginer que je deviendrai riche
et célèbre mais je n'avais pas du tout
imaginé que ce soit à travers la
télévision
ce qui m'a surtout fait marrer c'est
qu'on m'a donné de l'argent pour faire
tout ce que je voulais
à la maison
de sentiment de Far West quoi de tout
est possible
on peut rigoler à la télé
les gens étaient torcher comme des
[Musique]
chocs
bon
[Musique]
soir bien sûr elles sont à chier la vie
privée moi ça m'intéresse
moi j'en parle à la fermeté
ta gueule vous êtes vraiment un [__]
[Musique]
j'ai fait gentiment
vous voyez bien les gens que j'aime pas
les gens ne vous trompent pas
sympathique
[Musique]
ça suffit mais ce qui peut prendre un
coup de boule en même temps
faire [__]
alors que je me croyais un choquable
[Musique]
ça se faisait nulle part ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
tu rêves et j'étais payé pour faire ça
depuis 1985 il bouscule les codes de
notre télé transgressif provoquateur un
solo impertinent charmeur insupportable
scandaleux plume prometteuse il devient
un enfant de la pub il est le premier à
comprendre que la télé se consomme comme
un produit génie créatif il a imaginé 24
programmes en 32 ans son parcours est
jalonné de succès de gamelle est devenu
aussi et là un engin est apparu une
trappe s'est ouverte et un petit être
est sorti
il a tout tenté tout osé il a reçu les
plus grands les plus fous les plus stars
les a confessé fait rire ou pleurer mais
surtout questionner est-ce que vous avez
un piercing sur le sexe c'est une
interview devienne sa marque de fabrique
c'est le roi de l'art divio il tutoie
les stars mais ne leur fait pas de
cadeaux alors là on comprend mieux le
personnage de Chantal Goya votre côté un
peu enfant attardé finalement enlève
enfant
l'homme en noir aime la couleur de la
nuit lorsque tout est fermé entre
délires chics et cultures rock la
musique est partout dans ses émissions
elle les ponts-tu ou conclue ses amis
l'appellent Thierry met son nom c'est
une marque
artisan ce soir il nous fait la totale
retour sur ses émissions culte et celles
qui le sont moins et d'abord celle qui
l'animal durant 8 ans tout le monde en
parle que personne n'a oublié un
téléspectateur sur trois chaque samedi
passe sa fin de soirée sur La Deux entre
un évêque un homme de lettres une porno
star Thierry soit ses invités des
moments en devenu culte la parole est
libre le ton décomplexé c'était le
rendez-vous incontournable de nos samedi
soir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'idée de je m'en en parle c'était
d'éviter le talk show à l'américaine
c'est à dire le One to One ou le mec il
est derrière son bureau il y a un mec
qui est sur le côté ils ont un mug enfin
je veux dire bon on connaît
[Musique]
Philippe Corti
Talia
et un vrai public de télévision
effectivement de mettre tout le monde
avec un principe de casting très très
simple c'était le dîner de tête avec une
[__] un archevêque c'était le choc des
mondes
[Musique]
stars du soir Jamel Jean d'Ormesson il y
a Chanel Jean-Christophe Mitterrand
Pascal Sevran
du stand avec l'abbé de La Morandais de
créer des ce que je fais toujours depuis
de créer des mélanges absolument
incroyables les juifs qui ont moins de
35 ans ils vont pas à l'église ils vont
plutôt en rêve et en boîte de
nuits au lieu de prendre des hosties
est-ce que vous avez déjà été excité par
un acteur oui
[Musique]
la prochaine fois
ça va bien
peut-être que les gens croient qu'ils
regardent deux chaînes à la fois une
chaîne où il y aurait mètre Capello une
chaîne où il y aurait Marilyn Manson pas
du tout c'est la même chaîne c'est
France 2 alors dans la cave du
grand-père de Marilyn il y avait quoi
Maître Capello dans la cave du grand
père de
photos zoophile j'aime pas trop les
animaux il fallait faire
un cheval dans sa vie
le don de la nature que vous aimeriez
avoir
la rapidité par exemple
[Musique]
il était pas très chaud donc je l'ai
convaincu on fait l'émission c'est une
catastrophe vous êtes toujours pas de
club résident à Saint-Denis le Red Star
a pas voulu finalement c'est pas que le
recteur n'a pas voulu c'est que le
restar joue en deuxième division et que
tant qu'ils sont un deuxième division
c'est un petit peu juste trois premiers
mois sont horribles je travaille avec un
producteur dont je ne citerai pas le nom
par Charles et chrétienne et là-dessus
il me dit bon bah tu vois je t'ai donné
ta chance j'étais je t'ai permis de
revenir mais franchement c'est pas bien
ça marche pas voilà et c'est là que j'ai
dit bon matin on va rappeler Catherine
barbe
c'est tout le monde s'emmerde en régie
regarde oh laisse tomber qui c'est qui a
fait ce plateau là c'est nul il y a pas
assez de pluie sur le plateau regarde
heureusement qu'il y a anguille mais
sinon
je te redonne une
chance donc j'ai changé de producteur
entre Noël et le jour de l'an ce qui se
fait jamais parce que d'habitude on
était avec le même producteur toute la
saison j'ai engagé Catherine et puis ça
ça a commencé à marcher évidemment très
très bien
[Musique]
chers amis chers amis bonsoir la chaîne
c'est France 2 et l'émission s'appelle
tout le monde en parle vous connaissez
le principe tout le monde en parle alors
tout le monde en parle en parle mais
avec la nouvelle année tout le monde en
parle a évolué l'émission sera et oui
plus divertissant
[Musique]
si vous étiez un accident ta coiffure
Patrick Sébastien ce soir indictateur le
coiffeur de Patrick Sébastien un
supplice être obligé de regarder Patrick
Sébastien savait les cheveux
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans cette
émission j'ai l'impression que ma veste
j'étais un [__] de froid il avait bien
cette connait vous connaissez pas la
mode vous êtes très jeune vous êtes des
vieux dans vos têtes est-ce que vous
vous sucez toujours le pouce
quelle est la dernière chose que vous
faites le soir avant de vous coucher une
petite branlette
je crois la France et le regarde la
France regarde vous connaissez Gad
Elmaleh le promoteur du film si je le
connais celui-là
il a des yeux du biche quand il veut je
lui fais son fantasme
une femme superbe coucher avec vous elle
vous propose même un million d'euros
personne ne le saura jamais est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord direct
il y a même pas besoin de dire une femme
superbe
ramène-moi Shrek
[Applaudissements]
pour 500000 balles
le mot le plus con en amour merci je
vais te dire c'est quelqu'un
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un qui m'a reconnu pendant
les rapports
[Applaudissements]
vous allez bientôt prendre
mais c'est
pas
quand j'ai fait de la télé je me suis
dit qu'il fallait sortir du discours
promotionnel préprogrammé que ces
gens-là arrivaient avec quelques
éléments de langage et que ils allaient
nous vendre leur film leur livre leur
disque avec les mots qu'ils allaient
utiliser dans toutes les autres
émissions alors que l'interview formaté
là d'un seul coup
ça permet de leur faire parler d'autre
chose et puis de les surprendre aussi
très jeunes on va faire une interview
première fois
[Musique]
votre premier baiser sans la langue
la maternelle la première fois
ce soir votre premier souvenir quand
j'ai embrassé un garçon derrière le
préfabriqué à Cogolin j'avais 3 ans
très précoce
était premier désir mais j'ose pas vous
la poser parce que c'était le même genre
c'était le même premier rendez-vous
amoureux c'est encore le même
péché c'était le même premier péché
quand même il a du pot premier chagrin
d'amour c'est Roger
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
reprendre les 10 kilos que vous avez
perdu oui est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à tourner dans un film
pornographique
ou d'autres
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous installer à Limoges
est-ce que par amour c'est terrible vous
seriez prête à vous aiguiser en Elton
John
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
devenir son esclave sexuel moi je suis
et vous
mais peut-être
on dit
en fait j'avais une cinquantaine de
formats
je me servais d'une 15 quinzaine en gros
interview nul êtes-vous favorable à la
paix dans le monde c'est ça des Marceau
et puis un jour j'en ai eu marre de
faire l'interview première fois
l'interview alerte rose l'interview nul
bon et là j'ai pris des auteurs donc à
des Raoul et Stéphane Ribeiro qui
m'ont inventé à ma demande des
interviews à domines si tu as vu qui
était spécialement conçu en fonction de
l'invité la première qu'on a fait je me
souviens c'était l'interview
thermolactif de Damart pour Françoise
Hardy est-ce que comme tous les garçons
les filles de votre âge vous portez des
thermolactiles de Damart tous les hivers
papa ce soir
et c'était horrible est-ce que comme
tous les garçons les filles de votre âge
vous avez les jambes lourdes en fin de
journée
je confirme
horrible et il y a eu aussi avec le
boxeur Forman j'ai l'interview suicide
Foreman quand vous redevenez champion du
monde à 45 ans le combat a été truqué
non
vous croyez qu'on se souviendra de vous
comme champion du monde ou comme
marchand de grill
on arrête on arrête
donc maintenant la plupart du temps je
fais aussi des fois des classiques genre
par amour etc mais d'une façon générale
effectivement on crée des interviews en
fonction de l'invité ça va la santé là
je sens que ça faiblit un peu on va
faire une interview cercueil alors
c'est la première fois alors comme ça
Jean-Pierre vous êtes mort
mais dites moi vous aviez passé un pacte
avec le diable pour durer aussi
longtemps oui oui uniquement pour
ennuyer mes camarades il disait il va
bien partir je suis là Rebecca t'as pas
un couvercle
maintenant tu es pas trop de boîtes de
nuit on va faire une interview boîte de
nuit
quel est le temps de la nature que tu
n'as pas et que tu voudrais avoir
Jean Gabin je voudrais l'avoir une de 30
cm
j'ai pas vu Vincent Cassel depuis
Blueberry donc vous êtes remplacer on va
faire une interview Vincent Cassel
ça se passe bien avec Monica oui
qu'est-ce que ça fait quand on entend
répéter toute la journée que sa femme
est la plus belle femme du monde
qu'est-ce que vous aimez chez Monica
Vincent
qu'est-ce qu'elle a de plus beau selon
vous
et Vincent vous draguer toujours un peu
vous quand même
c'est normal
il faut regarder les autres femmes pour
apprécier la sienne
il a changé moi je suis pas [__] mais là
j'avoue que j'ai jamais trompé ma meuf
mais c'est pas faute d'avoir essayé
j'ai des centaines de groupies qui
m'attendent tous les soirs après le
spectacle mais mais elles viennent avec
leurs parents
vous insultez vos assistants est-ce que
connard est une insulte
est-ce que comme tout mon animateur vous
avez fait des implants Cyril alors
franchement si j'avais fait des implants
est-ce que vous croyez vraiment que
j'aurais choisi ça non forcément on
dirait un paillasson on peut mettre
welcome sur ma tête
en quoi Franck Dubosc est-il
complètement nul ah en égoïsme ah oui
c'est toujours les autres les autres les
autres les autres les autres qu'est-ce
qu'ils pensent de moi
[Rires]
alors le nom tout le monde le connaît
c'est Darmon le prénom c'est Gérard
l'âge 55 la taille de quoi
non après il y a une autre question qui
est taille du sexe et à part là c'est
taille 80 1 80 la taille du sexe Gérard
je sais que c'est une question qui vous
absène un petit peu tout à l'heure
il y en a qui ont des cartes de bons
clients
[Musique]
dans une émission faut toujours avoir le
bon copain Darmon par exemple c'est le
bon copain je crois que 19 fois dans
l'émission
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir Comment ça va très bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va qu'est-ce que tu es beau dis donc
merci
avec moi s'il te plaît on mangera
elle est très balayée par la vie comme
tu dis comme ça ça te va bien tu sais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la région
il est trop fort
mais c'est vrai qu'on a toujours besoin
d'avoir quelqu'un sur qui s'appuyait
quelqu'un qui rit à vos vannes dont
personne ne rit enfin c'est utile tu
sais ce que
il va dans un supermarché faire les
courses machin en étant en vacances il
fait les courses il pousse le caddie
avec Laetitia à côté et tout il pousse
le caddie pousse le caddie il y a des
mecs dans supermarchés qui distribuent
des des biftons de tombola tu vois comme
ça là il en est un dans le caddie et
tout et il entend au micro au bout de 10
minutes et le numéro
évidemment Laetitia lui fait johnny
c'est toi il y va et le mec déjà bon il
est surpris de voir Johnny tu vois hein
alors attends il a gagné son point en
chocolat bon
son poids parce que c'est la promo en
noix de coco chocolat de noix de coco et
et 150 euros par jour
150 euros par jour
jusqu'à ce qu'ici de Bounty
merci
il était là c'était le bon copain il me
faisait marrer il était complice quoi ça
c'est très important d'avoir dans un
casting moi je dis toujours cette
semaine qui est le bon copain bon alors
la maman j'ai bafik et bon copain pour
l'éternité
je l'ai vu hier moi ah oui à la soupe
populaire bon par plusieurs
reconnaître et c'était assez touchant il
venait prendre sa soupe il était il
avait froid il était allo
Jean-Marie
c'est Jean-Marie mais le haut-parleur
qu'on en profite
je bosse ma poule l'autre con qui est
toujours en deuil je t'expliquerai
le cheval en fait c'est comme ça qu'on
s'est connu bah dis donc tu te ventes
de cheveux
on oui sérieusement
demain je suis à Châteauroux pour aller
110 Berry samedi à Romorantin
Aurillac enfin et ça continue comme ça
le Kawan c'est de la box thaï pratiquée
par des gens assez assez corpulent
souvent assez peureux
ce qu'on appelle des [__]
et puis on descend il y a la finale des
8 meilleurs au Japon là vous défiler en
Europe puis en maillot
c'est quoi pour vous la soirée idéale à
deux
c'est gênant
[Rires]
je mange pas de ce pas là c'est pas le
pain qui va manger c'est pomme de terre
premier truc parce que d'où je suis je
peux te mettre un coup de boule dans
l'anus et puis ça m'impressionne pas du
tout c'est que des prises connues des
coups de genou je vais te présenter mon
public toi d'accord
[Applaudissements]
c'est nourrit aussi des gens avec qui on
travaille c'est normal par exemple bah
film a beaucoup appris quand il voit
Raymond Barre et qui dit Raymond une
question quand on est homme politique
est-ce que c'est plus facile avec les
gonzesses après je me suis dit mais on
peut tout dire à tout le monde en fait
il faut arrêter d'avoir honte faut être
audacieux on peut tout dire à tout le
monde mais c'est même beaucoup pas pris
le plus simple à maman pour faire taire
la rumeur serait quand même été de faire
comme chez l'autre faire un enfant non
faut déjà trouver la mer
pour déclarer au mois de novembre que
vous étiez en train d'écrire un film de
cinéma Doc Gynéco intitulé le plus vieux
métier du monde c'en est où
à Mougins il est ça va couper il va
rentrer dans une [__]
on faisait l'amour à trois avec un mec
moi j'aurais vraiment l'impression de
faire l'amour avec le mec et j'ai pas
envie de voir sur machin qui balotte ça
m'intéresse pas tu seras de dos tu
verras rien vous changeriez quoi en vous
si vous aviez une baguette magique un
peu moins d'argent peut-être
j'aimerais bien avoir votre esprit ah
c'est gentil
donc là c'est devenu le talk show
généraliste qui est une
particularité je dis pas dit ce mienne
ça serait prétentieux mais en tout cas
française dire que ça se faisait nulle
part ailleurs
l'émission est devenue le rendez-vous
incontournable du samedi soir crazy
vas-y vas-y fais-moi des compliments
jolie Coline Hubert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il a dit à la productrice c'est une
nanax je pourrais me faire donc ça
c'était décisive
[Musique]
ouais il a dit Isabelle Camus faut la
prendre parce qu'elle vraiment j'ai
envie de me la taper quoi
je sais où je suis maintenant c'est vrai
que tu devrais faire du cinéma porno
parce que tu avais un joli cul tu as
bien fait de pas l'écouter quand même
tu préfères dîner avec un sourd muet ou
avec un aveugle bègue
[Rires]
ton les journées qui sont longues ça
c'est Diderot merci beaucoup d'être venu
beaucoup je vous aime beaucoup ça c'est
Patrick Bruel ah
car je ne suis pas Patrick Bruel
non non non non
je ne suis pas Patrick Bruel et ça sent
trop
[Musique]
uelle Patrick Bruel oui quand tu étais
petit
tu regardais sous le bureau de la
maîtresse pour voir sa culotte
oui mais pas petit un peu plus tard
tu profitais de ta notoriété pour
obtenir des avantages particuliers et
voilà on y est on est en pleine dans la
rubrique fellation groupée allons-y
[Applaudissements]
moi je suis pas si par les gens en
général c'est à dire que c'est très rare
que je dise oh là là il est super mais
les stars d'Hollywood je trouve qu'ils
ont un truc et c'est vrai quand j'ai eu
par exemple
Brad Pitt il était extraordinaire
[Musique]
pendant deux heures il était là il était
sympa il répondait aux questions quand
on est une star de niveau est-ce que
c'est vrai qu'on peut exiger un jet
privé pour entrer dîner le soir à la
maison
on peut refuser d'assister aux
cérémonies des Oscars parce qu'on a un
truc mieux à faire ce jour-là
est-ce que quand on est une star de
Hollywood quand on est sur la plage on
rentre le ventre
est-ce que le matin quand vous vous
réveillez des fois vous avez vraiment
une haleine de poney
avec Tom lui avait
alors vous avez déclaré en parlant de
Brad Pitt si j'étais homosexuel il
serait en poster dans ma chambre
oui on vous a prêté des liaisons avec
les plus grandes stars d'Hollywood avec
Angelina c'est c'est vrai colline
j'aimerais bien par contre
je sais toujours est-ce que vous avez
envie de baiser
que préférez-vous dans le sexe alors
[Musique]
est-ce que vous êtes déjà barré avant
qu'une de vos conquêtes ne se réveille
Jane Fonda par exemple
tout le monde en parle son livre de
mémoire j'ai trouvé quel était d'un
naturel d'une gentillesse et tout donc
c'est vrai qu'il y a un professionnel
chez les anglo-saxons qui est absolument
qui est connu d'abord et ensuite qui est
incroyable c'est assez intéressant
d'ailleurs de regarder une autre femme
faire avoir un orgasme jamais vu ça
personnellement
j'ai vu des
quand avez-vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois
vous changeriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique
si vous voulez aider quelqu'un il ne
faut pas lui donner du poisson il faut
les apprendre comment le péché c'était
difficile mais intéressant c'était
d'obliger l'inviter à passer sous les
fourches codes de l'émission
[Musique]
attention les petites mains ah oui oui
il faut faire ça
vous permettrez d'être indiscipliné
comme je le suis dans d'autres enceintes
VO que même les maîtres du monde le font
de créer moi un mouvement
[Applaudissements]
c'était surprenant parce que on est
arrivé allez allez faire rentrer dans
nos codes à nous quoi et ça c'est très
jouissif
montrer de vacances avec des gimmicks à
Catherine disait ça marchera pas
j'écoute on va essayer donc on essayait
et puis c'est vrai qu'au bout d'un mois
il y en a qui marchait il y en a qui
marchaient pas
[Musique]
ils sont bien briefés c'est un vrai
public de télévision
consécration ultime ici ça le triomphe
ça c'est le côté publicitaire
c'est-à-dire d'inventer des trucs des
guinics qui captent l'attention tu dis
magnétos Serge
1 2 3 magnéto serre
ma demi-tour
[Musique]
2 3
est-ce que parce que tout le monde dit
magnéto Serge est-ce que on l'a déjà vu
[Musique]
la fin c'était devenu un gimmick la
pause bisous et évidemment
[Musique]
si tu deviens tactile en plus ça va
Bruce Willis par exemple vous devez vous
laisser embrasser sur la bouche par
Thierry Ardisson
[Applaudissements]
il se retourne sans entendu parce que on
a les pistes de tout le monde on peut
montage on a monté la piste et il se
tourne vers
Florent Emilio série il lui dit il est
gay
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai déjà entendu cette question que
vous faites cette vous vous pensez
[__] ou faire [__]
je préfère embrasser parce que se faire
embrasser ça doit faire très mal
dans la pub j'avais appris à utiliser la
musique j'avais appris à trouver des
gimmicks donc tout ça je l'ai appliqué à
la télévision mais avec
une liberté totale
[Musique]
moi ce qui m'amuse c'est la création en
fait je suis devenu animateur parce
qu'il fallait bien quelqu'un pour
incarner mes idées mais en fait moi je
suis un mec d'idée je suis un concepteur
de pub
c'est de la dynamique
c'est quand même voir de trouver un
titre qui marche avec le visuel OK
jusqu'à présent il y avait des
journalistes des publicitaires des gens
de show business et maintenant il y a
des gens qui font les trois choses à la
fois on les appelle les multimédiattes
c'est un nouveau métier c'est un nouveau
mot comme charcutier ou menuisier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand c'est trop cette moi je connais un
fromage moelleux savoureux c'est le
chaud
[Musique]
Marie-France avait vu dans Rocket folk
la série décembre de police
et où nous avec Jean-Luc maître on était
des flics et c'était pas des interviews
c'était des interrogatoires donc c'est
déjà une interview à concept puisque on
avait transformé l'interview en
interrogatoire le haschich j'aime
vachement de toute façon au tennis on ne
fait jamais de contrôle les meilleurs
comme pétier Borg se drogue avant les
matchs sur conseil de leur médecin ces
déclarations sans détours c'est le
français Yannick Noah qui les a faites
dans le mensuel de jeunes Rock and Folk
celui qui a recueilli ses déclarations
de Yannick Noah Thierry Ardisson Noah
était-il averti du caractère un peu
sensationaliste de cet article de cette
autre interviews qu'on avait fait dans
le même série donc il connaissait le
style le style de descente de police
[Musique]
les questions qu'on vient de vous poser
c'est exactement les questions qu'on
pose en décembre de police c'est les
mêmes qu'on a posé à l'année dernière
Gérard de Villiers à Dalida et Yannick
Noah on a transformé l'interview en
interrogatoire
dans Marie-France je l'avais dit je veux
ça à la télé
plus pervers sauf que je dis Nathan mais
nous quand on fait un invité pour
descendre de police on passe je sais pas
à 3h à interviewer après on réécrit le
truc sous une forme d'interrogatoire
mais tu penses bien qu'on parle pas
comme ça aux gens j'y mets en télévision
va falloir parler comme ça aux gens donc
c'était vraiment compliqué parce qu'on
arrivait ça va connard
[Musique]
s
[Applaudissements]
toute ta vie
[Musique]
au bout de numéro Michel cotta qu'on
voit que Hervé Bourges vous avez vu ce
qui est passé sur votre antenne alors
bon j'ai dit non
elle lui dit le texte est-ce que tu es
vaginal anal ou clitoridienne enfin
c'est plutôt clitoridienne ou vaginal
comme fille je pense toutes les deux
essayez de l'autre je sais tout à fait
de l'autre
qui rentre à TF1 et qui dit à
Marie-France Baudière vous avez vu ce
qui est passé Marie-France sur la chaîne
France avait pas vu non plus personne
n'avait rien vu ça fait un scandale ils
ont arrêté
des centres de police il y a eu 6
numéros des centres de police sur TF1
et plouf c'est fini là il restait ce
coup à la une
[Musique]
en fait je remplacé plus ou moins sa
chef du sel je vois pas ce que j'avais
de commun avec ce soliste bonjour bon
dimanche bienvenue à Bercy Sall Marcel
Cerdan sur le plateau de scoop à la Une
j'y connaissais rien c'est dire que
j'avais un track la première émission on
a pris le bon dans une prise et le jour
dans l'autre et il y avait Salvador bah
écoute Henri heureusement que tu arrives
il était temps tu vas m'imiter d'abord
pour commencer le mec qui présente son
émission de télévision pour la première
fois ah bon je trouvais ça
extraordinaire d'avoir un seul Vador
Catherine barman ce n'est pas
l'animateur de choisir l'invité c'est à
la productrice c'est moi qui choisis je
dis d'accord mais c'est d'abord je
connais depuis que je suis tout petit ça
me fait du bien qu'il soit mon invité
pour la première émission ouais d'accord
bon et Henri Salvador avait dit
actuellement j'étais assis il avait dit
à un moment il regarde le public je sais
pas où ils l'ont trouvé je suis là mais
bonsoir messieurs mes dieux ah pardon
mesdames et messieurs aujourd'hui c'est
et c'est je suis très content de où est
la caméra
ça a duré très longtemps j'étais
extrêmement tracas alors Serge comment
va le petit Lulu ou le petit
célèbre tu vas être expert-comptable par
exemple alors là mon coup de pointe
d'ailleurs
ça m'empêchait pas de pousser des
questions insensées parce que je me
rendais pas contente en fait mais avec
tout ce que tu t'envoies tu avais pas
peur qu'il soit un peu Mongolo Lulu non
[Musique]
ma bouche pipe son père ou de sa mère
comment réussites-tu l'exploit de faire
vivre deux épouses sous le même toit
j'en ai personne avait osé lui dire
qu'il vivait avec deux femmes je suis
quand même super de vivre avec de
gonzesses et lui il faisait on n'a
jamais posé cette question
dans son slip sur scène
des fois sur scène ça durait tellement
longtemps c'était tellement bien que tu
avais des éjaculations sur scène c'est
vrai ça m'est arrivé ça m'est arrivé
mais j'étais vraiment bien ce jour-là il
faut croire j'espère que ça va t'arriver
aujourd'hui les gens ont commencé à dire
à partir de ce couple à la Une il y a un
mec le dimanche après-midi sur TF1
il est pas très bon mais il déménage
[Musique]
des problèmes importants à vie
personnelle on peut on peut le dire
maintenant tu as eu des problèmes
d'abord amoureux avec ta avec ta femme
une énorme star et quand tu es arrivé
dans une salle et que tu voyais qu'elle
était vendue à moitié ou au tiers ça
devait quand même bien de filer un peu
le bourdon quand même ça file le bourdon
faut chanter pour les gens qui sont là
hurle pas
kaaris ça fait plus modèle de Toyota que
rappeur non
genevièvement bonsoir vous allez en
forme comment ça va vous sentez de
prison là si c'est pour des questions
comme ça j'ai autre chose à [__]
ça fait longtemps que vous avez pas
frappé une hôtesse de l'air vous prenez
le train ou quoi non ça me manque tu
penses que vous avez fait des programmes
ces temps
pour moi ouais je veux dire pour toi
peut-être pas moi je posais des
questions quand j'ai commencé la télé
donc j'étais ultra tracker ce qui fait
que j'étais agressif
d'où l'idée de dire aux chanteurs
d'Indochine on t'a déjà dit que tu
chantais faux enfin des trucs absolument
infernaux parce que étant malheureux je
me disais il y a pas de raison que les
autres ne le soient pas aussi non mais
ta voix par exemple tu sais qu'on est
tout le temps que tu chantes trop quoi
est-ce que tu est-ce que tu as
l'impression de plus chanter faux
j'ai pas une voix qui fait que beaucoup
de gens j'ai pas une voix avec un temps
de musical à l'intérieur sinon c'est
conscient je chante pas faux dans le
sens que les notes sont justes
pourrais-tu mais
bon
c'était pas plaisant à faire quoi
je transpirais j'avais chaud j'étais pas
bien etc et un jour viens dans
l'émission Patrick Timsit et à l'époque
dans double jeu il y avait ces deux
noirs qui tenaient les torches comme ça
avec des tout petits slips et
Timsit il prend les couilles d'un des
mecs et ils ont
pas mal
[Rires]
à n'importe quoi
[Musique]
j'habite
star mais là quand même pour le disait
des blagues racistes
[Musique]
est-ce que
mon amour
[Musique]
c'est con et c'est rigolo
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir mais non pas bonsoir comme ça ça
fait ça fait folle ça c'est pas bien
bonsoir bonsoir mesdames messieurs
bonsoir bienvenue au folies pour double
jeu
92 tu faisais bien tu seras grand-père
et tu continueras de faire ça à tes
enfants
double jeu il faut savoir passer la main
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir Manon bonsoir papa bienvenue au
Folies Bergères pour l'émission de papa
Manon
tu sais ce qu'il y a ce soir dans
l'émission de papa Manon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce que tu tiens compte des attaques
dont tes programmes sont victimes au
sujet de la violence oui bien sûr
il y avait le petit ange qui était comme
ça le petit diable qui a fait une
fourche comme dans Tintin quoi et chacun
influencé à son tour quoi il y a eu
l'affaire rabbin des bois aussi qui a
fait beaucoup de scandales
gratuits
quand même j'ai fait également le
producteur également c'était les
isolations du film Robin des Bois Jacky
était déguisé en rabbin c'était Ramin
des bois je veux dire c'est de l'humour
de ma fille et c'est pas vraiment très
méchant tenez vous aimez Dorothée
madame s'il vous plaît
c'est pour toi c'est 30 francs madame
c'est de la vente directe
à l'enfant Dorothée m'interdit de
reprendre des disques que j'ai donnés
Dorothée qui vient de sortir tiens ma
chérie
vous êtes méchante avec vos enfants
allez jouer sur l'autoroute les enfants
allez hop Dorothée n'aime pas les
enfants alors foutez-lui la paix
Dorothée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai un début de réaction maintenant
je suis très mouillée
diffamation contre chaque matin on a
besoin de témoignage vous me dites que
vous avez participé à l'école des fans
et vous aviez 5 ans et d'essayer de vous
violer il essayait de vous violer ok
attention on va tourner mademoiselle
vous avez fait l'école des fans vous
aviez quel âge j'avais 5 ans et je
chantais très bien à l'époque
Martin m'a violé je tiens quand même à
le dire
ainsi car depuis vous êtes fait tirer
par Foucault et Sabatier
IEN à vous à l'époque pourquoi par
exemple
genre des attouchements des choses comme
ça quoi
c'est tellement traumatisant que quelque
part s'il est en face de vous
aujourd'hui vous lui diriez quoi [__]
voici de nombreuses victimes des enfants
qui sortent du casting de Jacques Martin
et qui se sont tous fait plus ou moins
violer ils ont tous été victime d'un
touchement des images terribles
Martin pédophile il a pas supporté il
est parti
Jacques mais viens
[__] tu es en train de me [__]
des conneries j'ai besoin de toi et tu
es invité numéro 1 de l'émission tu vas
pas tu as pas tu as pas de bail quand
même
vu mes émissions
quand même je sais pas on est sur la
même chaîne je te prie de m'excuser
je veux je te prie non non simplement
comme tu le ferais un soir où tu rentres
très tard embrasse-moi sur la bouche et
ce sera oublié
et je l'ai embrassé sur la bouche c'est
là où il était génial quand même
excuse-moi alors Jacques tu as eu une
enfance à la à la Dickens un peu un peu
ton père avait fait la guerre de 14 il
était parti à 20 ans faire la Grande
Guerre il en était revenu complètement
et que ce centre et buvin quoi un peu
c'est un euphémisme il buvait tout le
temps il en est mort oui il en est mort
mais il a pris son temps c'est un homme
alors toi tu t'es retrouvé au collège tu
étais mal vu parce que ta mère payée en
oui un petit peu mais sinon tu sais tout
toi je sais tout c'est très important de
voir quelques détails véridique
convaincre l'invité qu'on sait tout même
si on sait pas tout avoir du chocolat au
collège mais il a lu ma vie la vie
privée moi ça m'intéresse ça m'intéresse
parce que voilà quoi je veux dire on se
définit par sa vie privée et c'est vrai
qu'on peut en parler à condition d'avoir
les bonnes infos tu es né à Alger à Oran
à Oran Oran Algérie tu as passé ton
enfance à Passy
non je passais mon enfance à massif
c'est
pas grave quand tu étais petit donc tu
voulais être aviateur c'est ça pompier
exactement parce que j'aime le feu c'est
un truc qui j'aime le feu si c'est pour
dire des approximations on se fait
rembarrer dans les 30 secondes si tu dis
au mec des points très précis il va
avoir du mal à t'échapper alors un jour
donc tu tu voulais dessiner une BD qui
se passait dans une radio et c'est comme
ça que tu es rentré à Radio Monte Carlo
c'est comme ça que
oui ça exactement
c'est comme ça qu'on peut obtenir des
choses je me souviens de Jean-Claude
Brialy
je lui parlais de la voiture de son père
qui était une 403 décapotable je dis oui
la 403 elle avait des roues à rayons et
des pneus flamants et là le mec se dit
si c'est ça il sait tout c'est comme les
flics hier soir vous étiez au restaurant
avec telle personne
après il te demande ce que tu as fait
après le restaurant tu te dis si c'est
que j'étais au restaurant avec telle
personne je peux pas lui mentir vous
avez 10 ans quand une quand une copine à
vous fait des photos de pub vous êtes
folle de jalousie à ce moment-là vous
téléphonez à toutes les agences
artistiques et vous faites vos débuts
sur scène à 11 ans
vous avez eu toutes ces informations
vous maquillez pas avant l'âge de 17 ans
tu peux pas savoir quel est un œil
tatoué dans le dos
vous étiez prête à tout arrêter pour
partir vivre en Australie mais François
Ravard votre manager
Maurice Jarre vivait dans un deux pièces
à Issy-les-Moulineaux aux îles du patin
à roulettes dans l'appartement il y
avait un couloir et l'appartement était
tellement petit ça se terminait dans les
chiottes et vous avez toujours LA
cicatrices comment il sait ça moi je
sais pas comment il s'appelle
Gérard Jugnot pendant tes vacances à
Royan
t'es-tu masturber en pensant à Annette
[__] mais comment il sait je t'ai
élevé chez les curés et c'est vrai que
la confession c'est quelque chose
extraordinaire quand même on rentre dans
un truc on dit au curé j'ai fait si j'ai
fait ça
quand j'étais petit je sortais de là
j'ai l'impression d'être tout blanc mais
pur et tout c'est génial
[Musique]
du samedi soir
avez-vous commis le péché d'adultère
une fois en Turquie
ça il faut savoir une petite fille
on en parlera après on s'entend du
confessionnal mais je mettrais bien une
petite pénitence moi j'ai gardé ce côté
confesseur un peu confesseur cathodique
habillé en noir un peu clair jiman quoi
et j'ai même fait dans dans Double Jeu
l'interview confession donc dans un vrai
confessionnal est-ce que ton fils
Mathieu est baptisé oui on n'a jamais su
si c'était ton vrai fils ou ton fils
adoptif c'est tout à fait mon vrai fils
c'était une
[Musique]
c'est à dire que c'est
il a vécu avec moi d'une manière un peu
compliquée
à cause du désordre
de la jeunesse qui était ma jeunesse
mais en tout cas c'est mon fils c'était
extraordinaire parce que on était aux
Folies Bergères le moment on faisait
interview confession on entendait les
pas dans une église sans recréer
l'ambiance avec de l'écho comme si on
était vraiment dans une église etc il y
a eu des moments il y a eu des moments
magiques évidemment dans cette interview
est-ce que tu vois toujours sa mère
[Musique]
la drogue tu es beaucoup de gens
qu'il a élevé
je suis élevé mais pas très bien c'est à
dire que je ne suis pas
assez bien occupé que j'étais
sans doute un peu tyrannique avec lui je
lui empêcher de respirer quoi si tu
devais mourir là quel serait la seule
chose que tu voudrais lui dire à ce
moment-là
je t'aime
ton premier mariage c'est génial cette
quinze ans et demi non c'est ça non non
16 ans et demi deuxième mariage on
oublie troisième mariage extraordinaire
[Musique]
ou connu chez mort parce qu'elle
habitait chez Coluche on s'est téléphoné
ce soir là que lui schéma le 19 juin 86
on s'est revu on s'est marié on a fait
un petit et il est né le 19 juin 91
c'est bizarre
Coluche situé aussi en moto
vous dites je ne pense pas dans ma vie
avoir aimé un homme
[Musique]
ah non non c'est pas grave du tout ah
bon et je le reconnais je vais dire que
la plupart des gens sont comme moi un
amour absolu je ne l'ai pas connu en
tout cas moi je ne l'ai pas connu
oui quelque part j'espère le connaître
avant de mourir
on est très heureux que tu sois là ça
nous fait vraiment plaisir alors comment
on est content vous allez faire une
surprise Giulia
moi j'adore les surprises moi j'adore
les moments de télévision en fait j'aime
quand la télévision il se passe un truc
inattendu quelqu'un qui font en larmes
quelqu'un qui claque derrière quelqu'un
qui s'en va quelqu'un va et c'est vrai
que les surprises ça m'a toujours
fasciné moi je pleurais en regardant
sacrée soi-même est-ce que tu te
rappelles le temps que tu as passé un
avion venir me voir en Italie j'étais
petite fille je m'en souviens que
émotion un pareil tu me disais alors
maman quand est-ce que tu arrives
et j'avais du travail beaucoup de
difficultés etc et bon finalement
j'arrivais
et je me souviens je savais que je
devais partir et un jour
chez mon parti
étaient arrivés et puis tu m'as vu et
puis des années après
tu peux pleurer encore alors
j'ai lu comme ça par hasard ton petit
cahier comme ça
ouais je te le dis tu avais ton petit
journal de bord quoi
et puis j'ai vu
au moment a fait un plaisir
je croyais qu'elle était partie puis
elle était restée
mais ce soir elle est partie et j'ai
pleuré
sur le bateau que tu composes adieu mon
pays ouais tu veux pas nous faire un
petit bout
j'ai quitté mon pays
j'ai quitté ma maison
ma vie ma triste
ce trait ne sent raison
[Applaudissements]
j'ai quitté
mon soleil
j'ai quitté ma mère bleue
leur souvenir se réveille
bien après mon adulte
très facile je suis très émotif et quand
je voyais sacrée soirée je me disais
[__] c'est quand même une super
émission et tous les mercredis soirs
j'étais devant sacré soirée alors que
j'ai chié tout le monde à la télé tout
le monde pensait que je suis très
méchante Thierry en fait je pleurais
devant sa quelle soirée
retrouvailles en direct sur le plateau
de bain de minuit Jean-Luc Godard à la
Carina 20 ans après combien de temps
tous les deux
[Musique]
67 ça fait 20 ans c'est un événement
alors vous êtes content de vous
retrouver
dans une émission de Pierre Bellemare
ça vous a manqué qui vous qui vous
appelle pas
[Musique]
on peut tout dire à cette heure-là
je suis un peu surprise c'est pas quoi
dire c'est vrai que c'est un moment
difficile parce qu'ils sont pas vus
depuis l'époque elle se retrouve avec
lui devant une
caméra de télévision etc mais moi en bon
ça dit que je laisse le silence quoi je
dis rien
et c'est à cause de ça vous êtes quitté
finalement c'est parce que vous aviez
pas assez à lui donner maintenant parce
que c'est que ce grand amour qu'on
connaît
moi je pense qu'on peut l'être alors
beaucoup plus
et que demain est toujours un autre jour
[Musique]
c'est plus dur intelligent c'est de rien
dire et je me dis que si je parle il va
se raccrocher à ce que je vais dire
alors que si je dis rien à bientôt
obligé de dire quelque chose
mais le moment est bien l'autre chose
qui a changé votre vie c'est votre fille
Louise
mais là en fait ça me change mais je
pourrais même pas l'exprimer parce que
c'est c'est je suis complètement
c'est comme quand on vient de se prendre
un coup à la pointe du menton je suis
séché quoi
je suis
j'admire je peux qu'admirer ça me ramène
à des choses enfin c'est bouleversant ça
fait du bien est-ce que le fait d'être
père maintenant vous rend plus indulgent
envers votre père
oui mais j'avais déjà fait un peu de
travail là-dessus quand même
sinon il y aura une mort d'homme
quand tu rencontres des gens que tu
connais pas il faut toujours se trouver
un point qui te relie le mec te dit moi
j'ai longtemps vécu à Nice je suis
niçois il faut toujours avoir le truc si
tu veux qui te qui te relie à lui d'une
façon d'une autre tu vois ça me permet
quand même de créer des liens quand le
mec je vais lui faire avouer c'est
fréquentations et là-bas quand tu étais
au Vietnam tu as chopé un peu non
c'est pas tellement on est vraiment
éloigné quoi moi dans les années 70
j'avais beaucoup à Bangkok là
[Musique]
tellement marqué la scène d'amour dans
l'avion là
à l'époque j'étais avec une bronzesse
j'avais demandé de se faire couper les
cheveux pareils se faire tendre comme
elle les cheveux et tout non des
conneries
jusqu'à ce qu'on baisse dans l'avion
comme Emmanuel d'ailleurs
je reçois un dossier je cherche la
pépite c'est-à-dire je lis le truc d'un
seul coup je tombe sur un truc je vais
me laisser pas vrai quoi
c'est formidable c'est comme un
chercheur d'or qui trouve une pépite
dans le ruisseau quoi là ben un coup je
me dis mais c'est dingue cette histoire
là évidemment je sais que ça va être ce
dont les gens parleront à la machine à
café le lundi matin quoi mais l'autre
point c'est votre identité sexuelle
maintenant
[Rires]
jusqu'au mariage comme très bizarre il
veut retrouver une certaine forme de
virginité c'est vrai franchement
répondez-moi est-ce que vous avez déjà
essayé les mecs
[Musique]
donc vous vivez à Londres vous êtes un
petit peu rebelle comme ça vous faites
de la musique et à ce moment vous êtes
obligé de rentrer en Amérique vous
rentrez en Amérique de toute urgence
parce que votre père a été arrêté pour
fraude à l'assurance
c'est vrai effectivement mon père a
passé 8 ans en prison
oui j'ai perdu mon père pendant 8 ans
du parti deux fois village évidemment
elle est partie
ça m'a jamais empêché de leur dire ce
que je voulais leur dire mais c'est vrai
que le
pire comme invité parce que une émission
il faut quand même qu'il y ait des
invités se cassent au bout de 2 minutes
c'est quand même chiant tu t'es dévoué
en reprenant ce poste car franchement à
part des emmerdes qui d'autre auraient
repris cette ville de
[Musique]
75000 habitants des réformes chocs et
des décisions fermes bientôt tu iras
plus loin que les roues et un jour toi
aussi tu seras connu dans l'univers
comme le célèbre Adolf sax l'inventeur
du saxophone
[Musique]
Robert ça suffit
je me souviens de Geneviève de Fontenay
une fois qui était parti comme ça du
plateau et je me mets à genoux Geneviève
écouterai moi Geneviève je suis arrivé
Laetitia elle est pas mal à poil
Laetitia à poil sérieux mais c'est pas
le problème c'est pas le problème
j'avais été choqué parce qu'elle faisait
dans dans Playboy et dans notre vie elle
aurait posé dans l'expansion il aurait
pas eu de souci dans votre beauté dans
Elma ça aurait pas été la même
connotation bon vous savez que Laetitia
est complètement manipulée par cette
Corée
mais c'est une secte hein
[Musique]
vous dire que Laetitia et moi vous
remercions de cette chance incroyable
que nous allons faire de devenir célèbre
24 heures
[Applaudissements]
Geneviève j'aime bien j'aime bien
j'aime bien non j'aime bien j'aime bien
je suis désolé j'aime bien j'aime bien
je suis désolé
et le pire coup c'est la lame on s'est
double jeu
et puis un moment je dis top coupure pub
tout le monde reste en place
et qu'ensuite c'était le service public
voilà il y a pas de pub non c'est pas de
la pub c'est des bandes annonces pour
d'autres émissions de la chaîne d'accord
c'est la première fois de ma vie c'est
pas la première fois que je m'engage
parce que j'ai jamais mis mes idées dans
ma poche
ta gueule ta gueule tu es un peu tu es
un peu un poète qui descendu de sa lune
qu'est-ce que je voulais dire qu'est-ce
que j'étais en train de dire la cantine
et je peux le redire encore qu'est-ce
qu'il y a je sais que c'est la dernière
mais faudrait payer la note de l'année
je suis désolé
ma vie j'ai eu quand on m'arrêtait une
émission c'était pas grave j'en faisais
une autre et puis quand on arrêtait la
suivante j'en faisais encore une autre
ça me dérangeait pas quoi je vais un
espèce de sentiment de Far West quoi de
tout est possible on pouvait faire tout
ce qu'on voulait en fait
[Musique]
tous les samedis soirs il va relever un
formidable d'effet vous tenez en haleine
pendant une heure pour vous empêcher de
zapper et conserver son argumente
même la qualité
le concept le plus fou je pense que
c'est hardimat
[Musique]
je pense que l'idée d'un animateur qui
est là devant une caméra à qui on
demande de faire l'audience et qui fait
tout ce qui peut pour faire de
l'audience je trouve que ça résume de
toute façon l'acide la situation de
l'animateur si vous
êtes il fait pas assez je suis viré
donc c'était assez fou le problème c'est
que j'étais pas capable de le faire
c'est à dire que il aurait fallu être
Hanouna c'est à dire il a fallu avoir un
sens du direct un sens de ce que j'avais
pas du tout vous n'arrivera rien comme
ça enfin franchement qu'est-ce que c'est
que ce cinéma là qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette en phrase ridicule qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce décor Rome pompier vous
croyez que vous allez vous rendre
sympathique avec ce déballage
mussolinien je présente ah oui mais
parce qu'il est là le problème Thierry
les gens ne vous trouvent pas
sympathique Thierry tu es antipathique
il y a un peu trop de conneries je
trouve je crois qu'il y a un peu focus
odieux je trouve vulgaire méchant
agressif
quoi que physiquement je trouve assez
attirant quand même aujourd'hui je ne
s'intéresse qu'à lui-même qui se fiche
du reste alors à votre place je ferai un
geste là encore pour montrer que vous
avez un cœur bon ben comme un porte en
carnet de chèque s'il vous plaît il est
dans la dans la poche de mon imperméable
écoutez je vais donner à la paroisse de
mon
de mon quartier voilà le catholique je
sais pas si c'est ce que vous avez
trouvé de mieux pour vous rendre
sympathique
discutez pas parce que sinon on va y
passer deux heures il donnera rien du
tout vous allez donner combien 10000 en
rapport à ce que vous gagnez j'aurais
été jusqu'à 15000 enfin donner 10000
n'hésitez pas bien il y avait des gens
qui étaient payés pour me faire rigoler
tellement j'étais tellement j'étais
flippé mais c'était un concept assez
dingue quoi alors j'espère que tout le
monde va bien regarder sinon une petite
baballe dans la tête
vous allez laisser cette bestiole
qui devrait l'avoir là dans la tête je
te le dis moi plus vous vous engueulez
plus l'audience monte
boulevard moi je vais te dire un truc ça
peut être le clan des bœuf c'est le club
des morts hein parce que j'ai buté moi
aussi
je veux dire bon mais les idées étaient
bonnes un jour il se dit bon bah
l'audience baisse je vais tuer le chien
je prends mon flingue comme ça
c'est moi
quand même j'ai fait
un effort
organisé un concours de petits donc les
filles devaient faire tourner la roue
alors elle venait
votre nom
[Musique]
autant de petits chats
en plein milieu des filles qui faisait
le casting il y avait quartier qui est
une perruque qui voulait revenir
absolument dans l'émission quoi ça moi
je suis prêt à tout aussi je peux faire
tout sur le bureau j'aime bien quand ma
tâche j'aime bien qu'on me battre aussi
le repeindre le studio oui c'est
d'ailleurs la vaisselle
c'est pas mal franchement c'est pas mal
après les résultats étaient pas au top
mais dans l'esprit c'était bien ici
notre deuxième invité Fanny Ardant
pierre Chazal consiste
[Applaudissements]
je suis mais qu'est-ce que tu fais là
Thierry ça va
j'ai plus d'oignons émission j'ai plus
rien à diffuser et j'ai plus rien à
[__] dans cette émission
allez fais monter l'audience vas-y vas-y
vas-y ça monte ça monte ça monte
peut-être sur le biceps vas-y ça monte
un plan ça monte ça monte bien
éventuellement
l'émission est entièrement nouvelle donc
on passe une autre vie chez moi avec
Rolin avec BD et toute la bande et on
écrivait enfin c'est impossible donc au
bout d'un moment on s'est soufflé moi ça
m'a gavé je suis là Pascal Joseph j'ai
dit j'arrête mais tu arrêtes quoi je dis
j'arrête je vais t'en faire une autre
du présent du passé et du futur vous
inviter du présent c'était les gens
étaient en promo tu as dit il veut mieux
être à poil dans un chef-d'œuvre que
habillé dans un navet
[Applaudissements]
les invités du passé c'est des comédiens
qui jouaient aussi bien John Lennon que
Beethoven que Adolf Hitler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est une équipe de bras cassés on
arrivait quand même à faire des
séquences comme celle-là
j'ai beaucoup de tendresse pour ces
émissions là parce que elles étaient
sans doute les plus créatives mais elles
étaient je n'étais pas assez
professionnel pour les réussir question
on m'a dit que je pouvais
rentreras pas même tout seul même avec
des copains c'est un club privé ici
[Musique]
quand on a fait 20 minuit il a vraiment
j'avais une émission qui me ressemblait
si vous aviez un seul argument avancé au
million téléspectateurs qui vous
regardent en ce moment quel serait-il
pour que ce soit il soit fidèle à bain
de minuit bah c'est ça ressemble à rien
quoi
c'est génial ah oui que ça dure encore
2000 nuits un jour je me suis dit mais
complètement con au lieu de faire une
émission dans un studio pourquoi tu l'as
fait pas l'endroit où tu te sens bien
c'est à dire au bain douche
[Musique]
reste stay le plus beau moment je crois
que c'était la première de Baby bonsoir
Julien bonsoir merci d'être à la
première de bonne minuit est-ce que tu
sais sur quelle chaîne
il y a beaucoup de chaînes
on l'a vu cette émission en compagnie de
de Claude chalet de Hubert ou comme ça
qui était les patrons des bains
donc on était dans un appartement
entièrement avec des miroirs partout
voilà il y avait plus sans la croix il y
avait les gens des Bains Douches c'était
une soirée mondaine en plus et c'est un
moment incroyable parce que les missions
étaient hyperchies hyper classe avec le
générique tourné par par mon Dino enfin
je veux dire c'était vraiment tout était
bien quoi
et ça je crois que ça restera quand même
mon plus grand kiff
je crois que c'est formidable et c'est
la meilleure de Paris ça c'est sûr mais
avec ravissement c'est le meilleur de
Paris
c'est très bien organisé et puis Julien
Clerc m'a dit que c'était pas du tout
drogue ma crotale et compagnie que
c'était au contraire tout à fait sain
vous avez le bon les renseignements
généraux vous en donner de bons
renseignements et 200800 merde donc il
fasse leur édition ici non je crois pas
jusqu'à présent non je crois pas ça va
ça se passe bien les petits trucs mais
ça va bien ça va bien
c'est quoi un partenariat avec moi à
part vous marier avec vous
je sais pas si c'est le rêve de ma vie
mais j'ai très très envie un jour de
d'élever des singes
tu as joué dans 5 des 10 plus grands
monnaies makers de l'histoire du cinéma
comment tu fais pour résister aux filles
il donne très rarement des interviews
comme tu le sais il n'aime pas ça il
n'aime pas être dans dans la lumière de
la rampe
il l'intérêt de tourner des émissions le
soir c'est que les gens boivent
les gens étaient torchés comme des rares
et c'était bien parce que l'alcool
libère la parole donc les gens
effectivement ils disaient des trucs il
faisait des choses qu'ils auraient pas
faire à jeun c'était évident
[Musique]
à épater les gens cherchant à nous
amuser c'est tout mais non c'est tout et
je bois par l'oreille pour le coup avec
une erreur
je bois par l'oreille
quand tu es dans une boîte de nuit la
nuit
on boit des coups enfin je veux dire ça
s'apprête à la confidence évidemment
c'était quoi ton pire moment
c'est quand on était méchant avec ma
mère
tu vois je dis pas au tout début de sauf
ma mère et ma soeur et moi mais elle
aime des gaines d'allumesuses et tout le
monde a pris l'insulter en attendant de
[__] alors si on la connaît c'est
tellement différent c'est comme moi tout
le monde imagine que je passe ma vie au
lit alors je vais mettre enfin
boire une coupe de champagne ou un verre
de Gevrey-Chambertin invité à 3 heures
de l'après-midi à part Sylvie qui est
vraiment alcoolique c'est très difficile
en 27 ans j'ai bu comme un homme normal
en trois siècles pas mal quand même
ouais j'ai dû boire pour trois siècles
pour trois siècles et tu buvais quoi
particulièrement
je n'irai pas jusqu'à dire de tout mais
du matin au soir oui
le foie qui a explosé qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé au point de vue gamma GT
j'ai battu les records
lamentable lamentable
ridicule on va l'encourager à ne pas
rechuter on a besoin de témoignage
d'anciens alcoolique vous dites que vous
buviez énormément et que maintenant vous
avez complètement arrêté de boire et que
vous n'avez jamais rechuté pour
l'encourager à ne pas rechuter d'accord
dire ça parce qu'on a besoin des gens et
personne veut nous le dire quoi non nous
on vous mettra un cas sur les yeux
écoutez excusez-moi mais je suis pas
alcoolique je vois pas pourquoi je vais
raconter des choses comme ça pour une
émission je veux dire je tourne monsieur
vous arrêtez de voir depuis combien
d'années mais pas arrêté de boire je
n'ai jamais bu j'ai quand même une belle
tronche de pochtron monsieur c'est
possible ça c'est super vous me dites
parfois c'est dur je suis tenté de boire
un petit coup et obligé
je suis tenté de boire un petit coup
enfin ça m'arrive de temps en temps quoi
on va faire la scène là où ils allaient
dégueuler dans le coin pour montrer les
fléaux de l'alcoolisme
l'image terrible qui je l'espère est
dans Jacques Anne plus jamais boire une
goutte d'alcool oh là là c'est une
infection on va faire la scène de la
rechute vous faites semblant de boire un
peu
l'image une rechute terrible
et oui il en met partout c'est
pathétique on prendrait pas en access
prime time que des gens soient
complètement déjantés le soir ça s'y
prêtait en plus ils attendaient dans
l'horloge pendant des heures de passer
sur le plateau donc quand ils arrivaient
ils étaient ils étaient torchés quoi
j'accueille la même chose pour moi
Simon libérative votre premier roman
anthologie des apparitions chez
Flammarion on fait beaucoup parler je
dirais même que tout le monde en parle
c'est le cas de le dire voilà alors le
pitch je vais le faire qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez
les invités c'était mon modèle est-ce
que vous avez pensé à torcher les
invités d'accord ok c'était vraiment un
truc c'était dans la check-list quoi
j'ai accueille maintenant Frédéric
Beigbeder
[Applaudissements]
si un jour il y avait des il était
tellement bourré il a pas pu rentrer sur
le plateau
il va venir vivre
non non il est couché par terre à la
loge en fait
il peut pas venir c'est sûr
elle me dit quand on vomit on peut pas
parler
[Applaudissements]
c'est de la forte
la courbe il y a pas plus merdique
ok ça arrête la tête ça te [__] en
l'air je sais pas ce qu'on veut dire
c'est parce qu'on est d'accord alors on
est très d'accord la coupe faut pas
toucher c'est de la merde j'ai essayé
moi de la battre on peut pas la battre
alors elle devient quand la connaît elle
devient un compagnon qu'on touche pas je
suis allergique à la gorge bon je parle
un peu vite c'est pas un problème je
suis un mec qui rappé pourquoi tu manges
que des légumes
vous posez la question sur le cabanisme
qui est pas terrible etc mais non moi je
veux dire une chose moi je suis contre
vous savez ce que je vois non les
éléphants roses tiens regarde
vous les voyez là bien sûr il y a deux
éléphants aussi dans une émission et
notamment une émission de service public
on peut pas faire la promo de ça voilà
sujet à reproche à vous faire c'est
celui-là je vous dis je vous le dis
comme ça entre nous un matin ici c'était
un jour d'émission je faisais bain de
minuit il y a six flics qui sont arrivés
dans cet appartement et qui ont commencé
à se balader dans tout l'appartement et
ils ont tout fuit ils ont rien trouvé
moi il m'emmène à l'actrice c'est ça non
ouais ouais le fils des stupes au début
c'est très sympa c'est un peu star ce
qui est Hutch je me dis c'est cool et
tout et après changement de trip il me
montre au premier étage je t'ai un
dealer je tiens un dealer ils m'ont dit
oui vous direz de l'adope et tout je dis
pas de l'anopie
Monsieur est-ce que Monsieur Ardisson
vous a vendu de la drogue et le mec dit
oui et là heureusement ce qui m'a sauvé
c'est que j'étais pas coupable dire que
j'ai dit attendez si c'est comme ça on
va pas tourner l'émission on va aller à
Lyon on va aller voir cette fameuse
mercière de Lyon et elle va vous dire
que je ne suis pas coupable donc quand
ils ont vu que j'étais prêt à annuler
l'émission et aller à Lyon avec eux
évidemment ils ont compris que j'étais
pas quoi ils m'ont laissé sortir
[Musique]
moi j'ai été un des premiers en fait à
la télé
apparaît normalement comme on parle
entre nous c'est à dire qu'on parlait
jamais drogue jamais de sexe c'est
rarement d'argent et c'est quand même
des sujets qui sont intéressants
j'écoutais l'intro de musique érotique
on dirait vraiment de la musique de film
porno
[Musique]
alors je vais vous lire les paroles
parce que on fait pas toujours gaffe
écoute bien sentir ta bouche et fronter
c'est un début épouser tous mes rêves
dans un délicieux va-et-vient et
doucement dès qu'elle était fini
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment je me pose des questions
pour lui j'ai regardé des
cassettes du chaud et c'est pour ça que
je suis venue ce soir donc en fait il
m'impressionne beaucoup il me rendrait
nerveuse
[Applaudissements]
on a l'impression d'être sur M6 le
dimanche soir
d'un regard incroyable
ne me regardez pas voilà je vous demande
un truc faites-le pour ma femme mes
enfants j'ai de la famille c'est gentil
arrêtez de me regarder voilà quand vous
êtes assis sur une chaise est-ce que
vous pensez bien à croiser les gens
vous l'avez les mains avant de manger
[Rires]
je sais que c'est une obsession parce
que je pense que d'abord ayant été élevé
chez les curés dans une famille catho je
pense que j'ai vraiment une revanche à
prendre sur la vie parlez-moi de votre
enfant quand j'étais petit je me dis en
noir puis je posais plein de questions
vicieuses mes copines à l'école puis un
jour quand mes parents ont acheté un
poste de télé en noir et blanc je me
suis dit qu'en faisant les mêmes
questions vicieuses
devant des millions de gens à la télé
mais je pourrais me faire plein de
pognon est-ce que vous couchez le
premier soir vous touchez voir la
fermeté
[Musique]
je ne mange pas de porc est-ce qu'on
peut être niçois c'est le clitoridienne
ça je réponds pas ce genre de question
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
expériences homosexuelles avec vos
questions là
est-ce que vous avez de gros seins
[Musique]
pour moi le sexe c'est quelque chose de
naturel c'est quelque chose de très
agréable évidemment et j'en parle parce
que ça fait partie de ma vie et je
trouve une bonne façon d'aborder les
gens évidemment c'est une façon de la
faire dire des trucs ou de les ou les
débusquer première partouze
ça c'est un camarade
qui me dit viens on va chez des amis
boire un verre
change de culottes on sait jamais c'est
après
et au bout de deux heures tout le monde
était franchement à poil il y avait que
moi qui va crochet
et puis là il m'a dit quand même
vachement coincé comme nana et tout et
là j'ai dit ouais franchement coincé
comme nana
non non
je te promets non mais pourquoi
aujourd'hui deuxième partie
est-ce que tu as des rapports sexuels
dans le noir
en pleine lumière là comme ça ici non
est-ce que tu fais l'amour ailleurs que
dans un lit oui non oui oui
des instruments non oui oui
ou non ok est-ce que tu regardes des
cassettes porno comme par hasard je
tombe sur Canal+ ça peut m'arriver de
rester tant de me détendre
professeur no comment on dit en anglais
il aime beaucoup Chantal Goya
on va faire l'interview
39% des Françaises refusent la fellation
et vous le premier soir
ceci est une [__] ceci est une tête
quelque part dans la tête il y a une
bouche je sais c'est étonnant
vous avez 85 ans
le Cogolin vous faites des
tomates
comme 39% des Français vous refusez je
vous adore mais je préfère cunnilingus
les parents ça compte pas dans un
endroit public dans une partie
[Musique]
de vos parents
regardez bien youporn quand même non
comme tout le monde comme tout le monde
voilà il est honnête ce que vous
préférez dans le sexe
est-ce que vous avez un piercing sur le
sexe
sur le sexe
c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
que
feriez-vous s'il ne vous restait que 24
heures à vivre
mec-là
et moi 12h avec ta femme
il y avait des filles qui arrivaient
mettons au standard une fille nouvelle
standard mais à 11h du matin on savait
s'il était vaginal clitoridienne si elle
avait un mec si elle avait deux mecs et
tout enfin je veux dire ça nous
intéresse bien alors les modèles il y a
un problème si vous avez pas de mec
vous dites je préfère être seul que mal
accompagné en cas vous dites
moi tu fais l'amour moi tu en as besoin
très bien et l'autre te dit la vie elle
ne passera pas
pourquoi vous n'avez pas de mec
parce que j'ai pas trouvé la Mecque de
ma vie encore
mis tous les garçons qui sont autour de
cette taille Michel oui
lequel préférez-vous
il a fait un film qui s'appelle Stan the
flasher
[Musique]
ouvrez les yeux
quoi ça va pas mieux je pense que les
gens en fait baissent pas assez je pense
que la société serait beaucoup mieux
si les gens baisaient plus si c'était
plus libre
à la masturbation
est-ce que tu ferais un film avec elle
c'est quoi elle est sérieuse
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien l'avoir
déguisé en sadomas
avec lequel j'aimerais tourner mon
prochain film je vais faire un value
officiellement un hot-dogner trophée aux
oeufs d'acieux aux précurseurs au
visionnaires merci
les rebelles d'hier sont aujourd'hui les
géants de l'histoire
[Musique]
c'était le concept donc une dérive
nocturne dans Paris alors au début il y
avait Jean d'Ormesson et les écrivains
qui puent s'en aller vers la fin plus
c'était plus c'était que
[Musique]
François
j'ai même alisé mon professeur
philosophique c'est ça
alors d'habitude
son sexe sort dès qu'il voit des femmes
qui ne peut pas toucher en face de lui
il y a eu des moments
un peu graves quand même avec des
prostituées la nuit des moments comme ça
qui était pas obligatoirement gay et
qu'il y a des choses qui m'ont choqué
alors que je me croyais un choquable
un jour en bas dans un truc où il y
avait les mecs qui se font donc se
transforment en bébé en lui mettait une
grenouillère mais adulte il avait un lit
d'enfants mais taille adulte et la bonne
femme
le talqué
elle lui donnait un biberon
mais quand tu les quand tu les changes
comme ça quand tu les quand tu les
lances il y a jamais un moment où ça
devient sexuel
il y a une érection mais un bébé de
trois mois à une érection un petit
garçon de 3 mois une érection bon c'est
normal qu'une érection parce que parce
que c'est un plaisir c'est normal le
bonheur ça se traduit par un plaisir un
plaisir c'est une érection c'est logique
la dernière de Paris dernière c'était un
dîner chez moi c'était l'anniversaire de
François Rollin ou François je vais vous
faire une esclave donc je lui dis à ton
cadeau qui est là on ouvre la porte il y
avait une esclave pour lui Rollin était
très gêné donc on revient à la cuisine
il y avait l'esclave à côté de lui il
s'est plus trop quoi faire et on lui
avait fait des cadeaux et à mon il y
avait un CD et il arrivait pas enlever
le fan du CD ça il devrait ça il y a
rien de plus chiant d'ouvrir
donc on fait ce dîner ensuite on part
avec l'esclave en laisse dans un club de
Saint-Germain qui s'appelle chez
chochotte et j'avais trouvé ça
formidable de faire une mission chinoise
c'est dans ma cuisine un dîner avec bec
BD quartier voilà toute la bombe Paris
Première vous voulez une émission Hebdo
et moi je leur dis une mission Hebdo
j'avais déjà une ça s'appelle tout le
monde en parle je sais pas pourquoi je
vous ferai une émission si si il faut
que tu nous fasses une émission change
mais j'ai fait un dîner chez moi et
c'est une émission de rêve
[Musique]
la vraie différence entre 93 et autres
émissions c'est qu'il fallait pas que ce
soit trop préparé le mec arrivé ça va
toi ouais qu'est-ce que tu fais en ce
moment là je sors un film la semaine
prochaine as-tu ça permettait de faire
la promo d'une façon habile et tout à
fait naturel
là le Téléthon
ça apporte un max
un jour il y a un mec qui m'appelle pour
les Téléthon il me dit monsieur faroudia
bonjour Est-ce que vous feriez le
Téléthon je suis désolé je suis en
exclusivité avec la sclérose en plaques
[Musique]
[Rires]
je ne peux pas non mais monsieur
n'importe quel
moment
qui vous donne deux fromages et on
passera les régler plus tard
[Musique]
j'avais rien à préparer je buvais des
coups je fumais les pétards j'avais des
gens sympas et à la fin de l'émission il
y avait quelqu'un qui venait jouer du
piano ou de la guitare c'est le rêve et
j'étais payé pour faire ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon premier boulot quand j'ai eu mon bac
j'avais 16 ans 166 donc je suis devenu
disjoquer disquaire au Ischia gogo et là
j'ai découvert la musique en fait j'ai
vraiment vu ce qu'on pouvait faire avec
la musique comment les gens aimer les
chansons comment suivant la chanson
qu'on mettait la piste était pleine
suivant la chanson qu'on mettait on
vider la bise j'ai vu ça j'ai pris
beaucoup de plaisir à faire ça
[Musique]
les chanteurs ont des noms de couleurs
Didier
[Musique]
attention
Lavoine prêt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
terre de deviner des musiques à des gens
c'est mon truc de disquaire c'est mon
truc de 10 jockey qui revient quoi
pourtant c'est un jeu à la con tous les
gens qui partent en vacances il jouait
ça dans la voiture bon mais moi j'ai eu
l'idée d'en faire un jeu d'en faire un
format disons en l'occurrence et moi en
fait je préfère que des blind test quoi
ce soir le blind test est consacré au
Comic qui chante et pour arbitrer le
blind test j'appelle mon Jean-Philippe
Corti
cortige je l'avais connu dans une boîte
qui s'appelait le choix skya Camargue
et ensuite il était à Paris au distrito
et je vais être formidable et donc quand
j'ai fait évidemment un bain de minuit
je l'ai pris
cortis c'est quand même le seul mec qui
est capable de mettre
à l'époque c'était très étonnant
maintenant ça et moi il mettait lui se
Mariano
[Musique]
il a vraiment moyen il m'a appris un
sens de la fête et un sens vraiment de
la musique festive
alors vous êtes DJ non c'est ça qui a
écrit sur votre passeport il y a écrit
quoi
ça fait combien là
ça fait 8 ans ça fait
plus de plus de 700 jours
cette nuit sont les plus longues
ça fait quelque chose quand même
Corti il était en prison donc sans
vraiment de raison parce que c'est pas
un dealer de drogue simplement il avait
monté une boîte qui marchait bien à
Saint-Tropez tous les concurrents ont
dit qu'ils vendaient de l'ecstasie en
fait Corti n'a jamais été marchand de
break sinon il serait beaucoup plus
riche il va en prison à Tarascon ensuite
à la santé et moi je j'en parle à Hervé
Bourges en disant écoutez je vais le
prendre dans mon émission il a besoin
pour sortir de tôle d'avoir un travail
quoi donc je prends encore qui et je le
filme on marche autour de la prison de
la Santé il me raconte tu vois les mecs
ils font si les mecs ils font ça c'est
la route et ça c'est là où on fait signe
ce qui manque surtout c'est la tendresse
en fait
tendresse
il parle pas à quelqu'un qui est dehors
parce qu'il a sa maman qui est en face
alors en sortant de tôle vous reprenez
un boulot à la télévision c'est grâce à
vous quand même c'est à dire qu'à
l'époque le maire de Saint-Tropez a
écrit à Hervé Bourges patrons de France
Télévision monsieur Ardisson son
émission fait travailler un repris de
justice les gens ont dit mais comment
repris de justice sur le service public
il a payé sa dette à la société et Hervé
Bourget a été formidable parce qu'il a
répondu au maire de Saint-Tropez ce
repris de justice comme vous dites n'en
est plus un puisqu'il a purgé sa peine
donc si Monsieur Ardisson veut
l'employer dans son émission libre à lui
et qu'elle était mais bon sentiment s'il
y avait pas eu Haribo je crois qu'on n'y
serait pas arrivé non mais c'est
vachement gentil parce que quand je
rentre en prison on a déjà reçu le
contrat de travail donc je l'ai su
et voilà
[Musique]
je veux lui dire allez mon bleu
tous ceux qui rendent les gens heureux
[Musique]
et on a passé des après-midi dans cette
cuisine
on faisait double jeu là
compris ce qui serait intéressant c'est
de faire un long travelling sur ses
bocaux
[Musique]
c'est l'humanité quoi j'ai découvert ça
c'est comment en fait je suis un mec
s'il est pas fait de télé je me serais
jamais vraiment intéressé aux gens
franchement la télé je t'ai payé pour
que j'avais pas le choix
il le fait d'être payé pour m'intéresser
aux gens fait que mais ça m'a beaucoup
enrichi en fait beaucoup plus que
l'argent que j'ai gagné c'est à dire que
dans des aventures humaines
d'échec de on trouve la vérité de
l'homme de l'humanité quoi je trouve
c'est très très intéressant c'est
peut-être aujourd'hui ce qui m'intéresse
le plus dans le boulot
c'est fini Jean-Louis Aubert va nous
faire un cadeau formidable parce que
chaque fois que j'arrête une émission je
mets voilà c'est fini
et là ce soir pour la première fois
Jean-Louis va me la chanter en vrai et
je te remercie
[Applaudissements]
c'est fini
on attend ressassé les mêmes théories on
a tellement tiré chacun de notre côté
c'est un refaire franchement je referai
tout pareil je sais que c'est un peu con
de dire ça mais des moments très
difficiles quand même j'étais je voyais
pas mes enfants ça m'a coûté finalement
mes enfants que j'ai connu après donc
c'est pas été évident ça a pas été
facile il faut pas croire
[Musique]
c'est fini en fait la rigolade j'adore
mais sans mes auteurs sont Baffie
j'aurais beaucoup de mal à rire moi
j'aime quand c'est le poignant moi j'ai
besoin d'émotions
on va pas s'y au revoir comme sur le
quai d'une gare je dis seulement bonjour
et fais gaffe à l'amour mais c'est une
trace je trouve ça important et je pense
que si quelqu'un s'intéresse à notre
époque il va avoir à coeur de regarder
ce qui se racontait dans tout le monde
en parle par exemple parce que c'était
vraiment le lieu un peu l'Agora la place
du village du samedi soir où tout le
monde se retrouvait pour parler donc si
on arrive à donner à ça un peu
d'éternité je trouve que ça
[Musique]
disons ça aide à vie
ne soit jamais amer reste toujours
sincère tu as eu ce que tu as voulu même
si t'as pas voulu ce que tu as eu il y a
une phrase de Barrès que j'aime bien
c'est tout obtenir pour pouvoir tout
mépriser et c'est vrai que je suis un
peu comme ça c'est quand j'ai eu quelque
chose je passe à autre chose quoi je
j'aime bien dire je l'ai fait et
maintenant je passe à autre chose mais
ces gens me dis mais pourquoi tu
finalement tu te remets en question tu
te renouvelles tu ressuscites à chaque
fois et tout bah parce que je méprise
que j'ai eu tout simplement donc tout
obtenir pour pouvoir tout mépriser
allez à l'année prochaine
[Musique]
il y a une image que j'adore c'est un
jour où il y avait Ray Charles dans
l'émission et j'ai mis Giorgio manman
[Musique]
Ray Charles quitte le plateau avec
George John myman j'étais détruit des
trucs complètement c'est peut-être
l'image qui me restera la lumière est
belle
[Musique]
quand vous êtes suivis
et je m'en
êtres de pain et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de innarditude abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu